my hands are on the steering wheel but
no I'm not driving this car now climbing
and spinning are actually the result of
this motion base or what's known in
Hollywood as a Gimbal and it's
controlled with this the Waldo a mini
replica of the larger gimbal base a
skilled operator can make it look like a
car is spinning out of control a
motorcycle is bumping along a road or a
luxury yacht is sinking now a lot of
these types of sets could move on their
own but letting the special effects team
at NAC effects fake the movements can
actually lead to more realistic results
on screen like in Hubie Halloween
the bike you see is actually on top of a
cart what made more sense to be able to
put it in a safe confined environment to
where he was sitting on the bike and he
could do all of his kind of funny gags
while still be moving through the
neighborhood but you have to balance
safety and freedom of movement the
bicycle was on the center of it and we
made it on gas shock so he could lean
side to side he could free pedal and we
also made it so the wheels would spin on
it but moving a set is not a
one-size-fits-all solution which is why
NAC switches between different motion
bases like one of the most rudimentary
the airbag the setup consists of four
bags filled with air to lift the vehicle
the crew will simultaneously move these
metal pipes to create basic shaking
motions this is a very old process
they've been doing this for years and
years I mean this is probably how they
did the car driving scenes and I Love
Lucy I should put my seatbelt on all
right I'm driving through the jungle
terrain let's go nowadays the airbag is
best if you need a few bumps on the road
but when it came to day shift NAC had to
safely film insert shots of the movie's
young actress while matching all of the
twists and turns of this car chase
their neck Mo bases come in handy for
these situations these come in four
different sizes the minimo the neck Mo
the mighty Moe and the mo the vehicle is
first raised up onto the base by a
forklift the team will strap it down by
its wheels so the suspension can still
function the steering Works freely so to
make it sort of realistic you're going
to want to steer as it's leaning
oh yeah
I'm hanging on for dear life you're
doing a great job it takes some getting
used to
there are six axes of motion to each
base each of them has 27 degrees of
pitch 27 degrees of roll and it has plus
minus 20 degrees of yaw which is this
twist here they could also heave which
is this straight up and down
and they could surge
which is this here this is surge trust
that I'm in good hands Campbell's moving
Joe here we go let's go looks like a
roller coaster
this is like really awesome these bases
are capable of small minute movements
that can replicate any surface
how you program the gimbal will change
based on the type of vehicle you're
programming it for take the yacht from
The Wolf of Wall Street a boat doesn't
move the same way as a car or motorcycle
just hold on tight so Jesse used this
gimbal to create Grand and sweeping
movements to match with the motion of
the open ocean would realistically look
like so if we had a boat on here it'd be
kind of
interacting with the waves the boat is
always going to want to kind of go back
to level for buoyancy and those six
degrees of motion elevated the movements
as the yacht goes through the storm we
could be rolling it side to side putting
a little bit of pitch and some heave in
there
Jesse can also control how smooth the
movements are you don't always want
every move to be fluid when it comes to
helicopter scenes like an Iron Man 3 and
Jumanji Jesse might lower the smoothness
from a three which he uses for a calm
ocean down to a level two you always
want to make sure that you've got some
vibration happening without that it
doesn't really work it is really what
sells a helicopter is that constant
turbulence but making movements read
well on camera is just as much about the
operator's technique like when it comes
to plane turbulence
and this man NAC founder Mark Noel would
know having worked on True Lies Sully
and Almost Famous he also worked on
Titanic which featured its fair share of
turbulence for Almost Famous director
Cameron Crowe needed to get the most
genuine reactions from the cast for this
scene so Mark started the actors with
small movements and saved the big ones
for last
keeps watching the performance and then
he kind of like would catch him when
they're not really aware and then and
then just we'd slam it if you want to
keep the the movements minimal in the
beginning to really be able to sell the
broader moves when you're getting into
your crash situation sometimes one set
requires multiple bases in Flight the
crew put the plane set on an airbag for
smaller bumps then for even rougher
turbulence they used the nakmo base once
the plane fully goes upside down the
crew moved to a rig capable of spinning
the actors 360 degrees however you don't
always have to switch bases to get the
right movements that day shift truck had
to move in all different directions so
the crew modified the base by adding a
turntable which could spin the car
around 360 degrees and you can see by
the look on Joe's face it's spinning
pretty good up there the more
exaggerated the moves get the more
add-ons are needed and as the Great and
Powerful Mark mounted this hot air
balloon basket set to a turntable placed
on top of the base but he then had to
send the balloon into a tornado they
just wanted it to gyrate all around and
then come back the other way all the
lines went to an Armature which supports
all the rigging and then we had shock
cord to keep it kind of taunt and then
that went to the ceiling to keep it so
that when the motion base went up and
down and spun it has swivel on it all
the rigging would go with it Mark
estimates this action took 10 tries to
get right but whether it's a hot air
balloon or a car Jesse and Mark don't
have to memorize every single move
that's because the Waldo controlled
moves are all fed through this computer
with that they can record each move and
play it back for multiple takes they
took this Precision a step further when
working on these creatures for the
Mandalorian by 3D scanning the rigs
creating the moves in advance and then
importing those into the bay
and outside factors can really sell the
movements like a wind machine
accompanying a motorcycle or water
splashing in the exact right direction
with the boat's moves no bit of a detail
in a moving set can be just for show
what reads really well with aircrafts
and helicopters is the set dressing in
the actual aircraft so if you had like
cargo netting wires or anything hanging
or dangling that reads really well to
going up and going down it was authentic
to what it'd be like going up and down a
really a bumpy terrain it's a very
unique sensation yeah